he's one of Hollywood's biggest stars
today but the road to success wasn't
exactly smooth for Ryan Reynolds he's
the first to admit that there's been
quote nothing meteoric about his career
which has progressed slowly since he
left Vancouver for Los Angeles from his
early struggles growing up to making
movies that even he never watched this
is how Ryan Reynolds went from college
dropouts
to becoming Deadpool honing his skills
Reynolds his father Jim was a former
boxer and policeman who passed away in
2015 and according to Ryan he wasn't an
easy man to live with Reynolds told GQ
sometimes it felt a little like a
military barracks you know get the fold
exactly right on the bed make sure
there's no speck of lint anyway the fear
of disappointing his father turned
Reynolds into a self-proclaimed
really nervous kid but it also helped
him develop skills that would serve him
well later in life he told the mag I was
extremely sensitive and incredibly
perceptive it was so acute that I really
was able to jump into other people's
skin 45 minutes of college as a teen he
landed a role on Nickelodeon's 15 but
after high school the acting gigs dried
up and Reynolds worked two jobs to make
ends meet he then enrolled in a college
criminology course but he lasted less
than an hour telling variety I'm not
being facetious I spent 45 minutes in
college and I turned around and said I'm
gonna drive to LA and try to get into
the groundlings just before he made the
move to California he landed a role on
the x-files though it did little for his
confidence I've got to kick some butt
like I'm sure Bruno's doing in heaven
right now spoiler alert it wasn't much
of a roll still Reynolds claims he got
bad advice from director Rob Bowman
saying he told me never to go to
Hollywood because I'd never make it
there and secondly that I could have a
very small yet profitable career here in
Vancouver doing small parts but Bowman's
discouraging words though he made
Reynolds all the more determined to go
for it two guys a girl and a breakout
star Reynolds is really big break came
when he won a role on ABC's two guys a
girl and a pizza place in 1998 the valve
at the end of the : 'it that regulates
discharge is the poopy chute in 2016 he
told Andy Cohen that he'd sign up for a
reunion in a heartbeat because he had so
much fun making the show which he
credits with giving him the confidence
to make it as a movie star but that
sitcom is I know it's the sort of more
in vogue to say you know that that a
film is where it's at and it's great but
I that job was so much fun for me
renamed after two seasons two guys in a
girl ed for four years providing
Reynolds with a steady income and lots
of experience which he would take to the
big screen party guy after two guys in a
girl wrapped Reynolds took on the title
role in college romp
National Lampoon's Van Wilder the film
was hammered by critics but became a
cult favorite I'm doing a human-interest
piece I knew well I'm flattered I'd love
for your piece to be on Van Wilder put
Reynolds on the map and led to numerous
offers but he told GQ four years after
that I was Van Wilder it made me the
party guy I would walk into a bar and
people would start lining up the shops
you could sum up my career at that point
as a free shot at a bar overcoming
anxiety in 2018 Reynolds revealed to the
New York Times that the anxiety he
experienced as a child still plagues him
today with two Deadpool movies under his
belt and an expose feature on the way
he's at the top of his game but told the
times I've always had anxiety both in
the light-hearted I'm anxious about this
kind of thing and I've been to the
depths of the
end of the spectrum which is not fun
what if I told you we can cure you and
give you abilities and say that you
sound like an infomercial but not a good
one after years of taking a hard-knock
approach to his problem he decided he
needed to change saying I realized it
was time to just effectively light a
match to my life and walk away it's the
best thing I ever did
today he keeps his anxiety in check
using their headspace meditation up the
Green Lantern curse after his role in
blades Trinity Reynolds's fortunes were
hit and miss he won acclaim for his work
in the ninth
Definitely Maybe and buried but bombed
with the Amityville Horror just friends
and smokin aces when Green Lantern came
around in 2011 he needed a hit but
didn't get it he said in an interview
with Variety so I represented the death
of the superhero for a while so you know
after Green Lantern I was bringing that
category I was pretty much unhireable
Reynolds has mopped the movie on several
occasions in the year since both on talk
shows and on social media if you could
rate the Green Lantern on a scale of one
to ten before you give it a three or
four and he didn't pull any punches when
it came to poking fun at Green Lantern
as Deadpool either in please don't make
the supersuit green or animated career
saving leak he lobbied hard for a decade
but it wasn't actually Reynolds that
convinced Fox to move forward with
Deadpool it was the fans the film got
the green light after test footage
leaked online and social media users
went nuts Reynolds told variety when the
leaked footage got around the Internet
it created this enormous groundswell I
credits Twitter users Facebook users and
Instagram users forgetting this movie
made with the failure of Green Lantern's
still fresh in their minds Fox was
hesitant to fund a superhero movie
fronted by Reynolds he admitted part of
the reason Deadpool wasn't greenlit
right away it was certainly because of
me if Robert Downey jr. was playing it I
don't know how much greener a light you
can get to make a movie so who actually
leaked the footage but
longest time Reynolds suspected that
director Tim Miller was behind it but
he's now convinced that an unknown Fox
employee got the bull rolling
Reynolds told Yahoo the initial leak
came from Fox they think someone
recorded the footage on their iPhone and
then released it and then once that
happened somebody hacked into blur
Studios and got the original footage in
high-res and put it online the rest as
they say is history
bring it on one night Willy thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out this other cool stuff we know
you're loved too
[Music]